We will now go through a
sequence of examples that
illustrate the different types
of questions that we usually
answer using a normal
approximation based on the
central limit theorem.
In general, one uses these
approximations to make
statements of this type.
That the probability of
the sum of n, i.i.d.
random variables being less than
a certain number, that
this probability is
approximately equal to some
other number.
Notice that this statement
involves three parameters, a,
b, and n, and you can imagine
problems where you are given
two of these parameters,
and you're
asked to find the third.
And this gives us the different
variations of the
questions that we might
be able to answer.
So we will go through examples
of each one of these
variations.
Our setting will
be as follows.
We have a container, and the
container receives packages.
Each package has a random
weight, which is an
independent random variable
that's drawn from an
exponential distribution
with a parameter 1/2.
And we load the container
with 100 packages.
We would like to calculate the
probability that the total
weight of the 100 packages
exceeds 210.
For example, 210 might be the
capacity of the container.
Since we will be using the
central limit theorem, we will
have to work with the
standardized version of Sn in
which we subtract the mean of Sn
and divide by the standard
deviation of Sn.
And to do that, we will need
to know the mean and the
standard deviation.
Now for an exponential, the mean
is the inverse of lambda
and the standard deviation is
also the inverse of lambda and
so we know what these
quantities are.
Then, the next step is to take
this event here and rewrite it
in a way that involves
this random variable.
So what we would do is that we
take the original description
of the event, subtract from both
sides of this inequality
this number n times mu.
In this case, n is
100, mu is 2.
So we subtract 200, divide by
this quantity, square root of
100 is 10 times sigma,
this gives us 20.
And we do the same on the other
side of the inequality.
This is just an equivalent
representation of the original
event, but we have here is
the probability that this
standardized version of Sn is
larger than or equal to this
number, which is 0.5.
And at this point, we can use
the central limit theorem
approximation to say that this
probability is approximately
the same if we use a standard
normal instead of Zn.
Now for a standard normal, we
can calculate probabilities in
terms of the CDF that's
given in the table.
But here, we have the
probability that Z is larger
than something, not smaller
than something.
The CDF gives us the probability
that Z is less
than something.
This is easy to handle.
This probability is 1 minus the
probability that Z is less
than 0.5, which is 1 minus the
CDF of the standard normal
evaluated at 0.5.
And at this point, we look up
the normal table, the standard
normal table, and value for
an argument of 0.5.
The corresponding value is this
one, so we obtain 1 minus
0.6915, which evaluates
to 0.3085.
And this is the answer to
this particular problem.
In the next example, we ask a
somewhat different question.
We fix again the number of
packages to be 100, but we're
given some probabilistic
tolerance.
We allow the packages, their
total weight, to exceed the
capacity of the container.
But we don't want that to happen
too often, we want to
have only 5% probability of
exceeding that capacity.
How should we choose the
capacity of the container if
we want to have this kind
of a specification?
So we proceed as follows.
We want this number, 0.05, to be
approximately equal to this
probability.
But now, we take this event and
rewrite it in terms of the
standardized random variable.
That is, we start from both
sides of the inequality and
subtract n times mu, which is
200, and then divide by the
standard deviation of Sn, which
is this quantity and
which is 20, exactly as in
the previous example.
And now, this random variable,
Zn, is approximately a
standard normal.
So we're asking for the
probability of the standard
normal is larger than or equal
to something which, using the
argument as in the previous
example, is 1 minus the CDF of
the standard normal, evaluated
at this particular value.
Now, what this tells us is that
this quantity here, the
value of the CDF, should be
equal to 1 minus 0.05.
So this quantity here
should be 0.95.
What does this tell us about
the argument of the CDF?
We can look at the table
and try to find
somewhere an entry of 0.95.
And we find it either
here or there.
We could choose either one, or
we might decide to split the
difference and say that we get
the value of 0.95 when the
argument is 1.645.
And so we conclude that in order
for this to be 0.95, we
need a minus 200 divided by
20 to be equal to 1.645.
And then we solve for a and we
find that a should be 232.9.
And we can choose the capacity
of our container this way.
Our next example is a little
more challenging.
Here, we will fix a and
b and we will ask for
the value of n.
Here's a type of question
that has this flavor.
We are given the capacity
of our container.
We want to have small
probability of
exceeding that capacity.
How many packages should
you try to load?
What is the value of
n for which this
relation will be true?
So we proceed, as usual, by
taking this event and
rewriting it in a way that
involves the standardized
version of Sn.
So we need to subtract n
times mu, which in this
problem is 2 times n.
We subtract it from both sides
of the inequality.
And then we divide by the square
root of n times sigma,
which is 2.
So we divide both sides of the
inequality by this number.
Once more, this event here is
identical to the original
event, but now it is expressed
in terms of the standardized
version of Sn.
This is a random variable
that's approximately a
standard normal, so once more,
we're talking about the
probability that the standard
normal exceeds a certain
value, and by the central
limit theorem, this is
approximately equal to 1 minus
the standard normal CDF,
evaluated at this particular
value here.
Now we want this quantity to
be approximately equal to
0.05, which, once more, means
that this quantity should be
0.95 and arguing as before that
we try to find 0.95 in
the standard normal table.
And this tells us that the
argument of the normal CDF
should be equal to 1.645.
Here, we get an equation
for n.
Unfortunately, it is a
quadratic equation.
However, we can solve it.
And after you solve it,
numerically or using the
formula for the solution of
quadratic equations, you find
the value of n that's somewhere
between 89 and 90.
Now, n is an integer, so you
could choose either 89 or 90.
If you want to be conservative,
then you would
set n to the smaller value of
the two and set n to be 89.
Our last example is going to
be a little different.
Here's what happens.
We start loading the container,
and the container
has a capacity of 210.
Once we load the package and
we see that the weight has
exceeded 210, we stop.
Let N be the number of packages
that have been
loaded, and this number
is random.
If you're unlucky and you happen
to get lots of heavy
packages, then you will
stop earlier.
We would like to calculate,
approximately, the probability
that the number of packages
that have been loaded is
larger than 100.
Now, this problem feels
a little different.
The reason is that N is not the
sum of independent random
variables and so we do not have
a version of the central
limit theorem that we could
apply to N. What can we do?
Well, we try to take this event
and express it in terms
of the Xi's.
And here's how we go about it.
What does it mean that we loaded
more than 100 packages?
This means that at the time
we were loading the 100th
package, we didn't stop.
And this means that at that
time, after we loaded the
100th package, the weight
had not exceeded 210.
So the event that we're dealing
with here is the same
as the event that the first
100 packages have a total
weight which is less than
or equal to 210.
But now we're back into
a problem that
we know how to solve.
And the way to solve it is to
take this random variable,
standardize it--
this actually is essentially the
same calculation as in our
very first example--
and we will get the standard
normal CDF evaluated at 210
minus the mean of this random
variable, which is 200,
divided by the standard
deviation of this random
variable, which is 20.
So we're looking at phi of 0.5,
which we look up at the
standard normal table, and
has a value of 0.6915.
So this was our last example,
and these four examples that
we worked through cover pretty
much all of the types of
problems that you
might encounter.
Of course, sometimes it might
not be entirely obvious what
kind of problem you
are dealing with.
You may have to do some
translation from a problem
statement to bring it in the
form that we dealt with at
this point.
But once you bring it into a
form where you can get close
to applying the central limit
theorem, then the steps are
pretty much routine, as long
as you carry them out in a
systematic and organized
manner.